now that we have completed the Emma
Stone makeup look on you and we ask you
some Dancing with the Stars yeah so we
know new season is coming March 20th on
ABC and we find out who's competing this
week you know you who your partner is I
do thoughts feelings emotions you can't
reveal who it is but when you found out
I can't yes I can't say very much but I
can't tell you that it's it's very
different a different partner that I've
ever had before on Dancing with the
Stars so should be interesting it should
be really entertaining you guys will
definitely be entertained watching us
I'm sure of it
but I I was super excited I didn't know
who he was so there's something for you
he's very very sweet very nice and
hilarious excited nervous I
okay so usually every season I'm really
nervous because it's a new challenge I
mean you're getting to know someone come
that you have no idea about I mean you
obviously don't know I mean you have to
spend 5 to 6 hours a day with them
teaching them how to dance so it's it's
all really nerve-wracking but this time
I'm just really really excited I it's
just so different so I'm excited to get
started
and you you actually know who everybody
is competing I know I feel like I just
it's very liberating
you have such a secret yet I mean so I'm
like taking joy in it right now but
everybody will know on March 1st this
Wednesday on GMA and you guys are gonna
be excited about the cast there's a lot
of good really good people and it should
be fun you said you kind of teased a lot
of very good girls are coming - yes very
good very very scary most unfair
okay can they not have a dancing
background or can you is it I think
there's got to be some criteria where
it's like ballroom exactly that's
exactly what it's like as long as you
don't know ballroom you're accepted on
the show you know even if you've danced
your whole life they're like come on in
there like that's fair those like
lifetime dancer kind of people don't
wind up winning exactly and that's the
thing is like they they have to have the
story they have to have the connection
with the audience and sometimes that's a
lot harder to do than the actual dance
part of it so we'll see what happens it
could be a very interesting season
you